I'm a chef and a food policy guy but I
come from a whole family of teachers my
sister is a special ed teacher in
Chicago
my father just retired after 25 years
teaching fifth grade my aunt and uncle
with professors my cousins
I'll teach everybody in my family
basically teachers except for me they
taught me that the only way to get the
right answers is to ask the right
questions so what are the right
questions when it comes to improving the
educational outcomes for our children so
there's obviously many important
questions but I think the following is a
good place to start what do we think the
connection is between a child's growing
mind to their growing body what can we
expect our kids to learn if their diets
are full of sugar and empty of nutrients
what can they possibly learn if their
bodies are literally going hungry and
with all the resources that we are
pouring into schools we should stop and
ask ourselves are we really sending our
kids up for success now a few years ago
I was on I was the judge on a cooking
competition called chop four chefs
compete with mystery ingredients to see
who can cook the best dishes
except for this episode it was a very
special one instead of four overzealous
chefs trying to break into the limelight
something that I would know nothing
about these chefs were school chefs you
know the women that you used to call
lunch ladies but the ones that I insist
we call school chef's now these women
god bless these women they spent their
day cooking for thousands of kids
breakfast
with only two dollars and 68 cents per
lunch with only about a dollar that
actually going to the food now in this
episode the main course mystery
ingredient was quinoa now I know it's
been a long time since most of you have
had a school lunch and we've made a lot
of progress on nutrition but quinoa snow
is not a staple in most school
cafeterias
so this was a challenge but the dish
that I I will never forget was cooked by
a woman named Cheryl Barbara Cheryl was
the nutrition director at high school in
the community in Connecticut she cooked
this delicious pasta it was amazing it
was a pappardelle with Italian sausage
kale Parmesan cheese it was delicious
like restaurant quality good except she
basically just threw in the quinoa
pretty much uncooked into the dish it
was a strange choice and it was super
crunchy so I so I took on the TV sort of
accusatory judge thing that you're
supposed to do master like why she did
that
Shirley responded well first I don't
know what quinoa but I do know that it's
a Monday and that in my school at high
school in the community I always cook
pasta see Cheryl explain that for many
of her kids there were no meals on the
weekends no meals on Saturday no meals
on Sunday either so Cheryl wanted to
cook pasta because she wanted to make
sure she cooked something that she knew
her children would eat something that
would stick to their rib she said
something that would fill them up Cheryl
talked that about by the time Monday
came her kids hunger pains were so
intense that they couldn't even begin to
think about learning food was the only
thing on their mind
the only thing
and unfortunately the steps they tell
the same story so let's put this into
the context of a child and we're going
to focus on the most important meal of
the day breakfast meet Alison she's 12
years old she's smart as a whip
and she wants to be a physicist when she
grows up if Alison goes to a school that
serves a nutritious breakfast to all
their kids here's what's going to follow
her chances of getting a nutritious meal
one with fruit and milk one and lower
and sugar and salt dramatically
increased Alison will have a lower rate
of obesity in the average kid she'll
have to visit the nurse left she'll have
lower levels of anxiety and depression
she'll have better behavior she'll have
better attendance and she'll show up on
time more often why well because there's
a good meal waiting for at school
overall Alison is in much better health
than the average school kid so what
about that kid who doesn't have a
nutritious breakfast waiting for well
meet Tommy he's also 12 he's a wonderful
kid he wants to be a doctor
by the time Tommy's in kindergarten he's
already underperforming in math by the
time he's in third grade
he's got lower math and reading scores
by the time he's 11 it's more likely
that Tommy will have to have repeated a
grade
research shows that kids who do not have
a consistent nourishment particularly
breakfast have poor cognitive function
overall so how widespread is this
problem well unfortunately it's
pervasive let me give you two stats that
seem like they're on opposite ends of
the of the issue but are actually two
sides of the same coin on the one hand
one in six Americans are food insecure
including 16 million children almost 20%
are food insecure in this city alone in
New York City 474 thousand kids under
the age of 18 face hunger every year
it's crazy on the other hand diet and
nutrition is the number one cause of
preventable death and disease in this
country by far and fully a third of the
kids that we've been talking about
tonight are on track to have diabetes in
their lifestyle
now what's hard to put together but is
true is that many times these are the
same children so they fill up on the
unhealthy and cheap calories that
surround them in their communities and
that their families can't afford but
then by then under the month food stamps
run out or hours get cut at work and
they don't have the money to cover the
basic cost of food but we should be able
to solve this problem right we know what
the answers are as part of my work at
the White House we instituted a program
that for all schools that has 40% more
low-income kids we could serve breakfast
and lunch to every kid in that school
for free this program has been
incredibly successful because it helped
us overcome a very difficult but barrier
when it came to getting kids a
nutritious breakfast and that was the
barrier of stigma see school serve
breakfast before class before school and
it was only available for the poor kids
so everybody knew who was poor and who
needed government help now all kids no
matter how much or how little their
parents make they have a lot of pride so
what happened well the schools that have
implemented this program they saw an
increase in math and reading sports by
seventeen point five percent
seventeen point five percent and
research shows that when kids have a
consistent nutritious breakfast
their chances of graduating increased by
twenty percent twenty percent when we
give our kids the nourishment they need
we give them the chance to thrive
both in the classroom MB on now you
don't trust me on this but you should
talk to Donna Martin I love Donna Martin
Donna Martin is the school nutrition
director at Burke County in Waynesboro
Georgia Burke County is one of the
poorest districts in the fifth poorest
state in the country and about a hundred
percent of Donna students live at or
below the poverty line a few years ago
Donna decided to get out ahead of the
new standards that were coming and
overhaul her nutrition standards she
improved and added fruits and vegetables
and whole grains
she served breakfast in the classroom to
all of her kids and she implemented a
dinner program why well many of her kids
didn't have dinner when they went home
so how did they respond well the kids
they loved the food they loved the
better nutrition and they love not being
hungry but Donna's biggest supporter
came from an unexpected place his name
was Eric Parker and he was the head
football coach for the Berks County
Bears now coach Parker and coach a
mediocre teams for years the Bears often
ended in the middle of the pack
big disappointment in one of the most
passionate football states in the Union
but the Year Donna
changed the menus the Bears not only won
their division they went on to win the
state championship beating the Peach
County Trojans 28 to 14
and coach Parker he credited that
championship to Donna Martin when we
give our kids the basic nourishment
they're going to fry and it's not just
up to the Cheryl barbers and the Donna
Martin's of the world it's on all of us
and feeding our kids the basic nutrition
is just the starting point what I've
laid out is really a model for so many
of the most pressing issues that we face
if we focus on the simple goal or
properly nourishing ourselves we could
see a world that is more stable and
secure we could dramatically improve our
economic productivity we could transform
our health care and we could go a long
way in ensuring that the earth to
provide for generations to come
food is that place where collective
efforts can have the greatest impact so
we have to ask ourselves what is the
right question what would happen if we
fed our so more nutritious more
sustainably grown food what would be the
impact
Cheryl Barbara Donna Martin coach Parker
and the Burke County Bears I think they
know the answer thank you guys so very
much
[Applause]